one of my friends he gets laid all the  time he's one of these guys that  complains about condoms i hate when  people complain about condoms dude  you're putting your penis inside of a  woman  shut up  all right it's a thin layer of latex  you're not eating food with the wrapper  on it you're getting laid get over it  well you just can't have anything  between you and someone else his dad's  like hey son give me a hug well get that  [ __ ] shirt off dad  yeah i want to feel this hug goddammit  let's go  yeah  oh yeah every time my friend has sex  with a girl he has to tell me about it  you know he's like yeah i was banging  this girl the other night there was  quite a smell  and i was like really was it bad then i  realized what i asked that  is it ever good has that ever been a  positive answer you know no it's never  like yeah i was banging this girlia  night there was quite a smell  cinnabon